now that we've warmed you up
how many Pokemon tattoos do you actually
have eight hundred nine all of them
Wow and now you've got every single one
every single why hide it well thank you
thank you well you can't see out of the
back hair sister yes true how quickly
could detective Pikachu get you to
confess if you were to commit a crime
under interrogation oh my god actor I'm
constantly lying I don't think I think I
can [ __ ] my way right through that
interesting interesting if Hugh Jackman
were a Pokemon mm-hmm what would his
name be and what would he look like oh
um I mean he's like like he'd actually
be a squirtle I mean that's just that we
know that even he knows that you know
that'd be like a squirrel he's just a
squirrel my name is Australian yes
squirtle perfect you went a little
method and prepared for this role you'd
have to go as as Pikachu yeah the trying
time I think for some everybody how was
the transition back into Ryan Reynolds
been since then um that's what we call
re-entry mmm takes about four or five
months to get my get my sea legs away
and yeah I'm still trying to sort of
find who Ryan references since the
episodes yeah my first day of like
working on the movie I was like maybe
like a hardened kind of like detective
Brooklyn accent or whatever and they're
like just just - Ryan Reynolds just do
you they hired you okay yeah yeah
interesting as you were kind of
preparing for that role and you had
certain things in mind obviously you can
only do so much with the script but you
probably had more ideas you have any
ideas for a potential sequel what you'd
like to see Wow I don't know there's a
lot of I mean I don't sequel doesn't
even have to have detective Pikachu in
it I mean you can do a sequel the
Pokemon universe is pretty friggin
expansive so I think that they could
probably do a lot of stuff in there I
would love to do it again I it's so much
fun I mean it's such a ball you know
we'll see that was a kind of a pun -
lets go there's nicely dumped on him I
don't even know my specialty are you
sure about a hundred gotcha do you think
previously you mentioned that because
you might live in a briar patch in Ryan
city center you think maybe he has an
apartment in a poker ball somewhere I've
always been curious much yeah maybe
write a little spacious studio suite be
nicely furnished well-appointed red coat
Yeah right it's actually a bad idea or
sealing windows didn't make those for
humans yet they do they actually do I
mean you've seen some of those hotels
that are just like you know like the
window is the only thing that
distinguishes it from a coffin right
that's like me I mean we're probably not
far off captured before I run out of
time with you today can you confirm that
the sequel if it were to be made is
actually titled detective Pikachu -
electric Boogaloo right
I want a Deadpool - to be called
electric Boogaloo home you can do both
right I think so - well I can't make
title two again because I could if it's
a like we could do it has anyone ever
done a shot-for-shot remake within a
year of something being really settled
in here think psychos the last time the
devil and Lion King right that's gonna
be a shocker Shelby I think coming up